times this season the Cavs have trailed
by double digits in the first quarter
ain't informed on inside about tant good
hustle move there yeah good job looking
away because you know LeBrons gonna
rebound on the back down it's this time
and Thompson came to the ball I guess
our man he slipped at home sometimes
teams in a row and poor starters have
the deads let's go
LeBron James steps the line welcome play
the guys are just too good 41 40
Brooklyn back in flips open from his
spot as he knocks it down
well it did a bad job of understanding
who had the ball that time type of
players you can be the civil to the team
2 o'clock jump out corner came to a ball
at Stockton
it doesn't have to be a three he still
that's the kind of careers out a little
bit to get a better angle and that sets
him up for the been shot it is good
teams at the line
[Applause]
[Music]
a minute nice little easy to push out
from the ground time to hold off
Washington your friend tops of pixies
[Applause]
toxin manage the once it does that 12
rebounds inside right down you click get
too far in that print like that match up
here he takes them downstairs Township
continue 109 106 LeBron to Larry Nance
Jr is leaving he's 3 of 7 from deep came
in at 20 inches cents LeBron James on
the finish ever using that pair that
pulls fees back down it gets did witty
moves dance open look stars it held
applause Larry Nance Jr with a 16 foot